[Music]
it's beginning to look a lot like
Christmas everywhere you go folks with
six-figure salaries are shopping in
galleries with a gift card made by Tom
in Ohio Wayne I need me it's beginning
to look a lot like Christmas roadsters
all around and while Tom can afford a
car he'll buy part of one but junk like
my legs in a tax credit check is the
wish of Connor and Ken hey and a dark
bottle tree that is partially free is
the hope of bobbing back while Tommy
takes the bus and each Vienna sausages
it's beginning to look a lot like
Christmas hear those sleigh bells ring
but what else could you expect where the
tax code so complex ensuring Josh Lee's
thing yes a car with the planets and
tarpaper Thomas the wish of Victor and
Vaughn a sedan that can drive and takes
used to arrive is the hope of Lenny in
lottery one Tommy pinches pennies now
but flushing I'm more wanting to look a
lot like Christmas sue
credits and bought the funniest sight to
cease when typical for DC they renewed
again
everything's renewed
again